demonstrations over the death of George
Floyd spread across six continents over
the weekend chance of black lives matter
echoed from thousands of protesters in
cities around the world
they were voicing anger not only at
racism in the US but also in their own
country senior foreign correspondent
Elizabeth Palmer was in London for one
of the largest protests in London
joining this protest mattered far more
than the lockdown rules thousands many
masked against coronavirus gathered
outside the American Embassy your
messages head over here and I will keep
fighting the same fight that you are
a few hours after the peaceful
demonstrations in the end the police
cleared the area around Parliament with
only a handful of arrests earlier in
Bristol a crowd pulled down the statue
of the 17th century slave trader Edward
Colston and then this symbol of
Britain's own racist past was heaved
into the river in cities everywhere
people joined in in Paris they marched
and Tokyo in Hungary a silent crowd took
a knee for 8 minutes and 46 seconds the
time officer shovin had his knee on
George Floyd's neck kovat 19 kept thai
protestors off the streets but on screen
in a massive zoom session but in Brazil
which has one of the worst coronavirus
outbreaks in the world demonstrators
came out anyway in solidarity with what
has become a worldwide movement the
focus of the protests in Sydney was on
Aboriginal people beaten are killed in
custody in 2015 Australia had its own
George Floyd David Dunne gay who died in
prison shouting I can't breathe those
desperate words have now been
transformed into a demand for racial
equality and justice
US embassies around the world like the
one behind me here in London have now
become the focal point for
demonstrations and black lives matter a
powerful new international rallying cry
Anthony Elizabeth Palmer in London for
us thank you Liz